we've talked a lot about ATP being the
energy currency of cells but I want to
dig a little bit deeper into that in
this video and as we'll see when we go
from ATP to ADP ADP plus a phosphate
group we have a release of free energy
if we look at just the system ATP's free
energy is over here but once hydrolysis
has taken place and now it's adp plus a
phosphate group the free energy has
dropped by roughly net by it's dropped
by roughly 30 and a half kilojoules per
mole or our Delta G is negative 30 point
5 kilojoules per mole and if you watch
the videos on Gibbs for energy this
tells us that this is a spontaneous
reaction Delta Delta G is less than zero
which tells us that this is going to be
this is going to be spontaneous
now when I first learned this I was like
well it's going to be spontaneous why
wouldn't all of the ATP just
spontaneously in all the water turn into
ADP and just release its energy is as
heat or whatever else and the key is it
has to get over this hump you have this
activation energy it has to go uphill a
little bit if it's if there's no enzyme
to catalyze it and the reason why we
have this uphill hump is it the way that
ATP gets broken up is that you have to
if we're talking about a water molecule
doing the hydrolysis which is kind of
typically what people think about
hydrolysis although it can so I'm going
to be done by a different molecule if
you think about the water molecule what
needs to happen is you need this lone
pair of electrons on this oxygen to be
able to do what we call a nucleophilic
attack on this phosphorus in this
phosphate group and while that happens
if that happens it forms this bond and
then these electrons these electrons can
be taken back by this oxygen which gives
its negative charge right over there now
you might say okay this might make a lot
of sense but you have to remember this
electrons are negative and they're
surrounded by these negative charges so
they have to overcome getting close to
these things so as they're approaching
these negative charges they want to
repel each other so you have to overcome
that and the way that's overcome is a
class of enzymes called 80 paces ATP ATP
ASE's I guess is the best way better way
to say it ATP
ATPase and what they do is remember
these enzymes are these big protein
complexes and and the ATP molecule can
bind combined in the right place and
they essentially try to surround the ATP
molecule with some positive ions so
let's say there's a positive ion here so
it can keep these electrons busy while
the water or whatever is doing the
nucleophilic attack can react cannot
have to worry about these electrons over
here so it might have a positive ion
here and remember the if we think in
three dimensions this thing is all
wrapped around in different ways around
the ATP molecule so this is the ATP this
is the ATPase and so by having the
enzyme over here you're lowering the
activation energy and so it might
actually look something more like this
and so the reaction can actually occur
so the reason why you just don't see
this happening all the time without an
enzyme is what you have to overcome this
time but once you have the enzymes they
can actually allow the the reaction to
occur
so this attacks this forms this bond and
now you say well you have another you
have another hydrogen right over here
you have a another hydrogen right over
here but this could get nabbed up by
another water molecule becoming a
hydronium ion which is actually what's
going to happen and then this character
takes away this pair of electrons
becomes a negative charge and we're left
with we're left with that phosphate
group has been broken off and then we
have our ADP and we have a release of
energy now typically you don't want this
to just you know release energy for no
good reason
most ATP ASE's are going to leverage
that energy that released this reaction
to phosphorylate a molecule in this case
you can kind of think that this
hydroxide has been phosphorylated but it
might phosphorylate something else or it
might change the confirmation of this
ATPase so this ATPase so it can do some
other type of work transfer molecules
against their concentration gradient or
their chemo electric gradient whatever
it might be you don't want to just
release the energy sometimes that might
happen if you just want to generate some
heat but usually you're going to do some
useful work for the actual cell so
hopefully this gives you a little bit
more appreciation for ATP and the
reaction by which again the hydrolysis
can occur this is called hydrolysis
because at least in this example we're
using a water molecule to break it up to
take off
phosphate group